this is the atwaters prairie chicken
a century ago there were a million of
them roaming around
today less than 100 are left in the wild
and are considered one of the most
endangered birds in north america
they are native to the coastal areas of
texas and louisiana
atwaters prairie chickens are small
averaging about a foot and a half in
size and weighing two pounds
they prefer short and tall grass in
their habitats and have a diverse diet
including grass shoots flowers seeds and
insects
urbanization and other forms of habitat
loss have been one of the major factors
in the steep decline of their population
the houston zoo runs one of the captive
breeding programs to help reintroduce
these critically endangered birds to the
wild
this is the atwaters prairie
chicken this is rainbow
a red-sided eclectus parrot
that deep green plumage with a tint of
blue signifies that rainbow is a male
bird
female eclectuses have deep red feathers
and until the 20th century males and
females were considered different
species
native to papua new guinea these
beautiful birds nest high up in the
tropical rainforests
they are considered to be extremely
intelligent birds and amongst the best
in talking ability for parrots
their vocal skills and stunning plumage
have made them highly desirable in the
pet trade
while logging and other forms of habitat
destruction have caused their population
to decline steadily
this is the red-sided eclectus parrot
[Music]
this is picasso a senegalese parrot
due to their popularity they are one of
the most heavily trapped birds in the
world
spread throughout western africa they
live in open woodlands and savannas and
feed on fruit seeds buds and
occasionally crop items
senegalese parrots are only about nine
inches long
and weigh up to six ounces
they may be small in size but they're a
gregarious bunch with lively energetic
personalities
their dark grey faces are complemented
by green and yellow plumage across their
body
senegalese parrots are incredibly
popular pets which has made the trade
import and export of wild caught parrots
illegal
[Music]
this
is the senegalese paris
[Music]
this is camaria a milky eagle owl
the largest african owl it is found
throughout sub-saharan africa the eagle
in their name refers to their large size
females are much larger than males
sometimes over a third bigger
they feed on a large variety of animals
everything from mammals fish rodents and
even large birds
they hunt from a perch using their sharp
vision to spot prey before flying in and
seizing them with their powerful
talons while it is a dominant bird its
population has seen a decline due to a
combination of loss of suitable habitat
hunting disease and drought
their slow reproductive rate has made it
difficult for the population to recover
quickly
this is the milky eagle owl
[Music]
this is oshie a toco toucan
the largest and most recognizable of the
toucan family they are found throughout
southern and central america
while their habitat is extensive their
population has continued to decline over
the last decade
their appearance is striking with its
iconic bill that covers almost 50
percent of its body surface area
it looks heavy but is actually rather
light
they use their build to plug out of
reach fruits from trees
toco toucans are considered extremely
gregarious and social birds living in
flux
the pet trade and the destruction of
their rainforests are the main cause for
decreasing population
[Music]
this is the toco toucan
[Music]
this is sylvester
a three-year-old sulawesi turrict
hornbill
endemic to sulawesi indonesia its once
plentiful population is now rapidly
declining
sylvester is on the smaller side at
about a foot and a half
hornbills in general are characterized
by their long curved bills
[Music]
this specific species makes its home in
the tropical lowlands swamps and forests
of sulawesi and nearby islands where it
feeds mainly on fruit with the
occasional small animal
but destruction of these areas has
caused a massive drop in population
that along with being hunted for food
and the pet trade has left this once
common bird harder to spot
this is the sulawesi turrictic hornbell
this is the gaito de las racas the
andean [ __ ] of the rock
also known as tunki in the indigenous
language of quechua
regarded as the national bird of peru
the gaiito de las racas is native to the
andean cloud forests
their most distinct feature is their
beautiful feathers
while the male has a large crest and
bright orange plumage
the female is more modest than its
counterpart with darker brown feathers
the brilliant colours help the males
stand out when courting for a female
partner
at breeding time males bob up and down
hopping around displaying their charms
females watch from branches nearby
their feathers have been an attractive
prey for the black market driving the
population down because of droughts
associated with climate change as well
as the massive destruction of forests
the future of their longtime home is now
being threatened
this is the gallito de las racas
this is pierre
a hooded vulture
native to sub-saharan africa hooded
vultures are critically endangered
they are the smallest of african
vultures only slightly larger than a
crow
they are scavengers and because of their
small size they end up wading by
carcasses and eating the scraps left
behind by bigger birds
adults have white feathers behind the
neck which forms a hood over its head
they live in forest clearings where it
rains coastal marshes and lagoons
hooded vultures are unafraid of humans
and can be found in villages and towns
often referred to as garbage collectors
by locals
due to a combination of hunting
poisoning and habitat degradation their
population over the last three
generations has declined over 80 percent
this is the hooded vulture
[Music]
you